one of the overriding reasons why modern
work is so boring is that we keep having
to do more or less the same thing every
day
we have to be specialists whereas we
would deepen our hearts surely be so
much more fulfilled if we could be
wide-ranging endlessly curious
generalists you can understand the
origins of restlessness when you look at
childhood as children we will allow to
do so much in a single Saturday morning
we might put on an extra jumper and
imagine being an arctic explorer then
have brief stints as an architect making
a Lego house a rock star making up an
anthem about corn flakes and an inventor
working out how to speed up coloring in
by gluing for felt-tip pens together
we'd put in a few minutes as a member of
an emergency rescue team then we try out
being a pilot brilliantly landing a
cargo plane on the rug in the corridor
we'd perform a life-saving operation on
a knitted rabbit and finally we find
employment as a sous chef helping make a
ham and cheese sandwich for lunch each
one of these so-called games might have
been the beginning of a career and yet
we had to settle on only a single option
done repeatedly for over 50 years we are
so much more than the world of work ever
allows us to be in his song of myself
published in eighteen fifty five the
American poet Walt Whitman gave our
multiplicity memorable expression I am
large I contain multitudes by which
Whitman meant that there is so many
interesting attractive and viable
versions of oneself so many good ways
one could potentially live and work but
very few of these ever get properly
played out and become real in the course
of the single life we have no wonder if
we're often conscious of our unfulfilled
destinies and at times recognize with a
legitimate sense of agony that we really
could well have succeeded at doing
something else if not our fault that
we've not been able to give our
multitudes expression the modern job
market gives us no option but to
specialize we can't be an airline pilot
one afternoon a week at research in two
days a month a singer-songwriter in the
evenings while holding down part-time
work as a political advisor a plumber a
dress designer a tennis coach a travel
agent and being additionally the owner
of a small restaurant
lebanese mezack however much this might
be the ideal arrangement to do justice
to our widespread interests and
potential the reason or we cannot do so
much were first elaborated at the end of
the eighteenth century by the Scottish
philosopher adam smith in the wealth of
nations Smith explained how what he
termed the division of labour massively
increases collective productivity in a
society where everyone does everything
only a small number of shoes houses
nails bushels of wheat horse bridles and
cartwheels but ever produced and no one
is especially good at anything but if
people specialize in just one small area
making rivets shaping spokes
manufacturing rope bricklaying etc they
become very much faster and more
efficient in their work and collectively
the level of production is greatly
increased by focusing our efforts we
lose out on the enjoyment of
multiplicity yet our society becomes
overall far wealthier and better
supplied with the goods it needs it's a
tribute to the world Smith foresaw that
we have ended up with job titles like
senior packaging and branding designer
intake and triage clinician research
center manager risk and internal audit
controller and transport policy
consultant in other words tiny cogs in a
giant efficient machine hugely richer
but full of private longings to give our
multitudinous self-expression one of
Adam Smith's most intelligent and
penetrating readers with the German
economist Karl Marx marks agreed
entirely with Smith's analysis
specialization had transformed the world
and possessed the revolutionary power to
enrich individuals and nations but where
he differed from Smith was in his
assessment of how desirable this
development might be we would certainly
make ourselves a wealthier by
specializing but we would also if he
pointed out with passion dull our lives
and cauterize our talents in describing
his utopian communist Society marks
place enormous emphasis on the idea of
everyone having many different jobs
there were to be no specialists here in
a pointed dig at Smith he wrote in
communist society nobody has one
exclusive
of activity but each can become
accomplished in any branch he wishes
thus it's possible for me to do one
thing today and another tomorrow to hunt
in the morning to fish in the afternoon
to rear cattle in the evening to
criticize after dinner without ever
becoming a hunter or fisherman a
shepherd or a critic it's a beautiful
but entirely unrealistic dream we have
collectively chosen to make work pay
more rather than be more interesting
it's a somber thought but a consoling
one to our suffering is painful but it
has a curious dignity to it because it
doesn't uniquely affect us as
individuals it applies as much to the
CEO as to the intern to the artist as
much as to the accountant everyone could
have found so many versions of happiness
that will elude them in suffering in
this way we are participating in the
common human lot we can be sure that
whatever we do parts of our potential
will have to go undeveloped and die
without ever having had the chance to
come to full maturity for the sake of
the real benefits of focus and
specialization
you